you've got a team here Superman you
bring this team together better than I
ever could
his strength doesn't matter how strong
you are or what abilities you might have
more human than I am he lived in this
world fell in love a job despite all
that power world needs Superman on the
team needs Clark how many times have you
played Batman now zone three well if you
count Suicide Squad three and how much
you think that's gonna be a five-time or
at least I don't know about that I'm
putting together a team people with
special abilities you see I believe
enemies are coming not coming Bruce
already here the others
where are they Arthur curry
the Aquaman
organic and biomechatronics body parts
he's a cyborg
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification
don't engage alone we do this together I
don't recognize this weapon we don't
have to recognize it we just have to
save it hey everybody so we got a whole
bunch of new Batman to talk about I was
originally planning on doing a Superman
video but then they just released a
whole bunch of information about Batman
in the TV universe and Ben Affleck just
made all these comments about his future
and the DC EU so it just felt like the
right time to do a Batman video but I am
still doing that Justice League ticket
giveaway I'll explain at the end of the
video be sure to subscribe to get
everything because they'll be review
stuff posting next week as soon as the
embargoes up so I'll try to explain
what's going on with that too very heavy
Justice League DC Comics couple of weeks
coming before we hit star wars territory
but that clip at the beginning really
gives you an idea for Batman's arc
through these last couple of Zack Snyder
films so you have Man of Steel which is
sort of like a prequel because Batman
doesn't appear on that but as much as it
started out like a Superman trilogy it
seems like more of a Batman trilogy
because you have classic paranoid Batman
after the events of that big Kryptonian
invasion and because of his sacrifice
and the visions that he's had he's
inspired in a way that he hasn't been
before and he tells Alpert he's more
human than I ever was he had a regular
job he was getting ready to get married
he had a human name he as an alien was
more human than me someone who was
actually born a human of Earth so if
you're not a big comic book reader you
may have heard about the Doomsday Clock
event that's coming up that's basically
the same type of idea where Superman is
the most human person of all even though
he's an alien from another planet and
has to remind someone else who is human
of their humanity in the only real
difference is that'll be a Superman
versus dr. Manhattan but even though
movie Batman
feels like he's spinning his wheels with
a team like Clark could do a better job
of this than I ever could
he's become the Batman that you would
normally think of when you picture
Batman in your head like when you think
about a comic book Batman story like
there's certain things he does certain
beliefs that he has certain ways that he
would react to situations
it helps recontextualize his arc during
Batman V Superman like
I would he act this way why was
Superbrand do these things it's because
they wanted to bring him on this journey
to where he is right here so after I see
the movie when I do my review video I'll
try to talk about whether or not I felt
like they were successful in taking him
to that place it sounds like they were
just based on the things that Ben
Affleck has been saying about the
character you know the footage we've
seen so far it's like Batman has become
a person again whereas before he was
more of like this mythic figure who had
retreated from society but you probably
saw that interview clip and are like
wait a minute does that mean that Ben
Affleck isn't going to be Batman anymore
the thing is is that all the actors the
executives they're sort of in a holding
pattern waiting to see how Justice
League does before they move forward
because Ben Affleck has said that he
loves being Batman and I totally believe
him but creatively behind the scenes
they sound like they're opening things
up to just be a little bit more
different like they don't all have to
flow from the same tone as Batman V
Superman Justice League and Man of Steel
they can be different things like
Aquaman will be a little bit different
even though it's connected to the DC EU
Wonder Woman's probably the best example
that if they didn't have those scenes at
the beginning in the end connecting it
to the picture from Batman vs Superman
you would think that that movie was like
a spin-off completely disconnected from
everything but you have the Matt Reeves
Batman trilogy that's coming up and you
have the second Justice League movie
which they're still writing and planning
on doing at this point so I think when
Ben Affleck is saying we'll see what the
future is holding one he's really tired
because he's been doing interviews all
day so it's not like he's tired of
hearing that he just physically
exhausted from the press tour and he's
just waiting to see what's going to
happen in the next six months or so
before he commits the next ten years of
his life to the character so if you hear
anybody saying that he doesn't want to
be Batman anymore that's completely
false
so it's not nearly as big a deal as some
people are making it out to be it's no
reason to freak out but the really cool
thing sort of in the separate TV
universe is is that they've talked more
about what's going on with Batman
because got the big name drop on arrow
so he officially exists in the arrow
flash universe they could have put Bruce
Wayne's head on that body as Bruce Wayne
left Gotham to hang out in Star City
recently no but since they did that big
name drop Stephen Amell has come out and
explained the conversation that he had
where he pitched the idea to the CEO of
Warner Brothers Geoff Johns and pretty
much everybody that's responsible for
controlling the Batman character like
anytime you want to use him you have to
get approval from Warner Brothers he
said he got really lucky back at
comic-con he knew that they would have a
big name that they needed a drop and
he's like wouldn't it be awesome if we
did Bruce Wayne he would open up so many
possibilities so here's where it gets a
little funny because Greg Berlanti he's
a very powerful person says Stephen you
go to Jeff Jones personally while we're
here at comic-con
in person and you'll probably have a
better chance of getting approval for
that than I would so one that implies
that Jeff Jones does have a certain
level of approval with the characters
that they use on the different TV shows
but when he was having that conversation
he also bumped into the CEO of Warner
Brothers who is standing next to all the
biggest producers that they have on
their films so literally the most
powerful people at Warner Brothers just
happened to be standing next to each
other at this comic-con party so Stephen
starts to pitch them on his idea for
Bruce Wayne and he has like this whole
big speech planned out in half way
through the first sentence the CEO stops
him short and says that's awesome great
go for it and that was the end of it
like literally he didn't get halfway
through his speech and the CEO was like
that sounds awesome do Bruce Wayne so
all of you are like wait a minute what
does that mean does that mean that
they're gonna do Batman on arrow
no that's not exactly what Stephen was
talking about he said that his idea for
Batman sort of the idea that them using
Bruce Wayne is that he's kind of an
antagonist for Oliver within the
universe he's somebody who knows exactly
what's been going on and does not like
Oliver at all so obviously Batman is a
hero he's never gonna be a real villain
but the idea is is that he's an
antagonist for Oliver Queen in the
arrowverse now he didn't mention
anything about how Bruce Wayne feels
about the flash or Barry Allen or
anything that he's done he would also
probably be pretty upset about
flashpoint and all the stuff that
Barry's been doing but it just clarifies
who the Batman is of the arrowverse he's
not the little kid from Gotham he's an
older person who's probably closer to
Oliver's age maybe even a little bit
older than that but he just said that
because they're allowed to do that it
opens up a lot of possibilities
story-wise for the future of this show
but just let me know
how you want them to use the Batman
character inside the arrow verse if he's
somebody that hates Oliver Queen
so hopefully that explains a little bit
more about what's going on with T V
Batman within the arrow verse obviously
very different character from the one
you've seen on Gotham so I think that
also just confirms that Gotham isn't
anywhere near being connected to arrow
or flash there's a new round of that
Justice League take a giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video Dane Phillips please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for brand new
flash and you can click here for brand
new Justice League thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight